il avait mordu la ligne blanche vous
avez vu non parce que c'est mal foutu on
obligé de la mordre au carrefour y aller
les trucs de pierre là qui bloque oui on
s'est fait chier à installer le truc
alors je sais comment ça marche
bonjour m botton réu il est mordu la
ligne blanche je regardais m'ont dit oh
toi qui vas tu c'est mal foutu mais ils
foncent à des difficultés pour baiser
les gens quoi parce que là où c'est ce
que vous perdez la seule permis c'est
combien de points dit le sait pas
cadets 2 points pour ça aujourd'hui
madame sur si ça va vite ça et pilar
comme il vous en retour au togo talkie
walkie
moi je suis obligé de vous mettre la
bande c'est dégueulasse le même mois en
tant que conducteur ça me choque et je
suis obligé de le faire parce que vous
faites ça ou ces trois jours à la plage
vous n'avez plus de permis mal à ce que
vous ayez la ceinture on a des paillis
vous êtes prudente mais si vous perdez
deux points quand même qu'elle monte
donc eu un défaut de présentation des
papiers excusez-moi temps pour moi je
laissais pas de point ses trois points
que vous tournez trois points si je fais
le tour de la voiture
j'essaie de retrouver un quatrième de
points je ne fais pas ce que je voulais
qu'on essaie d'arranger ça avec les
collègues
je viens parce que là franchement je
crois pas de facile vous avez l'argent
sur vous
comment voulez vous changer ça sans
arroser les flics
bon c'est ce que vous allez pas vous
allez aller chez vous et vous allez
prendre 205 en liquide
parce qu'il faut arroser tout le caire
d'accord on va perdre à distribuer ça va
faire 55 chacun moi je prends rien sur
vous parce que vous m sympathique et
comme ça ils vont laisser tomber
d'accord
prenez pas des billets marqué un des
numéros qui suivent parce que ça les
énerve
voilà pour les débiles et sur les choses
comme ça et puis ramené un peu de pinard
aussi des trois bouteilles de rosé
français c'est comme ça fonctionne comme
ça on est en démocratie n'ont fait que
ramener du vin quand même et puis le
journal éventuellement et pour moi vous
me prenez une cartouches de marlboro
simplement
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire moi je
vais arroser le collègue on me donnait 2
sans prendre la main à la main lui donne
par an
et puis il fait sens pour moi était
comme ça c'est bon voilà discrète
pour voir si ça va pour cette fois ci la
prochaine fois où pour les 400 francs
parce qu'il y aura les collègues et
après 800
bien qu'ils proposent ne suis pas g
comme ça nous ça nous fera des ronds
pour picoler tout c'est bon c'est mieux
pour nous je vous assure